but everybody seems to be in for some
economic pain how
economically painful is it going to get
for people in this country and i do have
one more question first of all
there's no doubt that when a major
nuclear power
attacks and invades another country that
the world is going to respond and
markets can respond all over the world
so there's no doubt about that
number one number two
the notion that this is going to last
for a long time is highly unlikely as
long as we continue to stay resolved and
imposing the sanctions we're going to
impose on
russia period what's your next question
i'm sorry the next question is
did you underestimate putin and would
you still describe him the way that you
did in the summer as a worthy adversary
at the time
he was i made it clear as an adversary
and i said he was worthy i didn't
underestimate him
and i've read most of everything he's
written did you read i shouldn't say i'm
not being a wise guy
the you you heard the speech he made
almost an hour's worth of speech is why
he was going into ukraine
he has much larger ambitions in ukraine
he wants to in fact reestablish the
former soviet union that's what this is
about and i think that his uh
his ambitions
are
are completely contrary to the place
where the rest of the world has arrived
you're confident that these devastating
sanctions
are going to be as devastating as
russian missiles and bullets and tanks
yes
russian bullets missiles and tanks in
ukraine
yes i am
[Music]
president if sanctions cannot stop
president putin what penalty can i
didn't say sanctions couldn't stop him
you've been talking about the threat of
these sanctions for several weeks now
yes but the threat of the sanctions and
imposing the sanctions and seeing the
effect of the sanctions are two
different
things two different things and we're
now going to he's going to begin to see
the effect of the sanctions
and what will that do how will that
change his mindset here given he's
because it was so weak in his country
that he'll have to make a very very
difficult choices of whether to continue
to move toward being a second-rate power
or in fact respond you said in recent
weeks that big nations cannot bluff when
it comes to something like this you
recently said the idea of personally
sanctioning president putin was on the
table is that a step that you're
prepared to take and if not bluff is on
the table
sanctioning president putin yes why not
sanction him today sir mr president
why not sanction him today
mr president if i can you detailed some
severe and swift new sanctions today and
said the impact it will have over time
but given the full-scale invasion given
that you're not pursuing uh
disconnecting russia from what's called
swift the international banking system
or other sanctions at your disposal
respectfully sir what more are you
waiting for specifically with the
sanctions we've imposed exceed swift the
sanctions we oppose exceed anything
that's ever been done the sanctions we
imposed have generated two thirds of the
world joining us they are profound
sanctions let's have a conversation in
another month or so to see if they're
working yes can i ask you about delansky
sir you spoke to vladimir zolensky
yesterday sir
what's the
what's the risk that we are watching the
beginning of another cold war and is
there now a complete rupture in u.s and
russian relations there is a complete
rupture right now in u.s russian
relations if they continue on this path
that they're on
and in terms of a cold war that depends
you have the vast majority of the rest
of the world and total opposition to
what he's doing
from asia to south america to
europe to around the world
and so it's going to be a cold day for
russia the idea you don't see a whole
lot of people coming to his defense
and are you are you if i could follow up
sir are you urging china to help isolate
russia are you urging china to help
isolate russia
i'm not prepared to comment on that at
the moment
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
no no no he's had his hand up a long
time thank you mr president how
concerned are you that uh putin wants to
go beyond ukraine into other countries
and the us will have to get involved if
he moves into nato countries well if he
did move into nato countries he will be
involved we will be involved the only
thing that i'm convinced of is if we
don't stop now he'll be emboldened
if we don't move against him now with
these
significant sanctions he will be
emboldened hey look
you know every uh
well anyway
can you talk anything more about your
conversation can you
mr president
[Music]
which is a major defense partner of the
united states is the india with fully
with you on the issue of ukraine and
russia
does the defense department of the
united states so india is one of your
major defense partners
is india fully in sync with united
states on on russia we're gonna be we're
in consultation with with india today we
haven't resolved that completely
okay thank you all very much
there we are joe biden at the white
house you're watching a special program
on the ukraine crisis which today became
the ukraine war let's go live to the
white house and uh u.s correspondent
mark stone and mark eventually after
what 13 or 14 hours we see and hear from
joe biden what do you make of what he
had to say
well many audiences that he was speaking
to he had to present
a united western front and i think he
did but he did not
announce the the rest or the full raft
of sanctions
that some have been calling for him to
do
given what happened last night he was
asked repeatedly about this idea of of
cutting russia off from the swift
banking system and he he made the point
that actually others have been making
through the course of the day that that
this swift banking system idea could uh
be somewhat of a red herring uh the raft
of other sanctions
against individual banks with huge
reserves outside of the unit of the
russian federation
could have as much or more impact that
was certainly uh his uh argument he
spent the first half of that statement
uh merely reminding people of the
gravity of the moment of what had
happened of the fact that the united
states had been warning that this would
happen for so many months now and that
his intelligence had got it bang on that
that precisely what they warned would
happen
did happen and then he outlined the raft
of sanctions that he says the united
states and the european union the uk and
others would now impose on russia he
seemed the subtext of what he said was
saying
seemed to be
that this will take this will be a very
very difficult few months maybe longer
for ukraine and that the fact is russia
is in the process of occupying ukraine
he didn't say as much but that seemed to
be the subtext but he made the point
that russia will feel the consequences
of that decision for many many years to
come vladimir putin will he said be a
pariah he also outlined a plan to not
only
buttress the eastern frontier of nato
even more with forces right now american
forces moving from western europe into
countries on the east but he talked to
about more american troops moving from
the united states to germany to backfill
those that are moving east he made
absolutely clear
that while ukraine may have been
occupied now by russian forces there is
no prospect of any nato member country
uh coming into contact with russia
without article five being triggered
article five an attack on one is an
attack on all that is why he said
american troops are moving to the east
of uh of uh
nato the nato territory and once again
he made a point he has made so many
times mark there is no prospect of
american troops moving into ukraine why
well quite simply because russia is a
nuclear power and we all heard what
president putin said in his statement
last night a very ominous threat to the
west
absolutely mark stone thank you very
much indeed
so what began as shelling in ukraine's
disputed regions has grown into an
invasion from the north the south and
the east it is the biggest attack on a
european country since the second world
war and moscow's most aggressive action
since the soviet invasion of afghanistan
back in 1979.
russia has confirmed a ground incursion
from crimea in the south while a
spokesman for ukraine's president says
the chernobyl nuclear power plant is now
under russian control in the north and
paratroopers seized an airfield just
outside kiev although president
salenski's office says that is now back
under ukrainian control
in a moment we'll hear from our
correspondents across ukraine and in
moscow with alex rossi in mariopol john
sparks in kharkiv and diana magnay
in the russian capital but first our
main report tonight comes from sky's
chief correspondent stuart ramsey here
in kiev
here we go it started before dawn
ukraine woke to explosions around the
capital kiev
it was the same across the country
these pictures from car keep in the east
enormous blasts also in the city of
denipro
[Music]
air raid sirens blared out across the
capital
above the clouds of fighter jet sword
over our heads russian or ukrainian we
don't know which
this was to be a day of targeted attacks
by the russian forces
whoever tries to hinder us and even more
so to create threats to our country to
our people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and it will
lead you to such consequences that you
have never encountered in your history
witnesses filmed this video of missiles
hitting the ivano frankevsk airport in
the country's west
russia appeared to be targeting
essential infrastructure helicopter
gunships hovering above a power plant
other power stations were targeted as
well
including the chernobyl nuclear power
station raising fears of an even greater
disaster
ukraine's president held an emergency
meeting with his top staff pledging the
fight will go on
what ukrainians should do
help the national defense join the
national armed forces territorial
defense
anyone with experience in the army
it's really important and we will not
let the enemy go any further on our
territory
russian armored personnel carriers and
other military vehicles crossed the
border from belarus into ukraine as
president putin's forces attempted to
take control
[Music]
military trucks also seen heading north
from crimea annexed in 2014
and tanks roll through the cities
including sumi holding a new phase in
this escalating crisis we now have war
in europe
on a scale and of another type
we thought belonged to history nato
allies condemn russia's invasion of
ukraine in the strongest possible terms
it is a blatant violation of
international law
in the capital streets usually teeming
with people became quiet not deserted
but fundamentally different to just 24
hours earlier
within hours it was clear a mass exodus
had started
this man and his family told us that
tried to get onto a train heading west
you said he was giving up though and
going home
without a car you're stuck he told me
the main roads heading out of kiev was
suddenly jammed with traffic
miles and miles of cues
people getting out of buses for a break
before continuing on
these women said they and everyone on
the bus was heading to the west
maybe then on to poland and safety well
for weeks now people have been telling
us that nothing's going to happen that
they're going to stay in kiev they're
going to stay in their homes but it has
happened and this is the effect it's uh
logjam
here this is the main road to western
ukraine as you can see
we're in a massive massive parking lot
now
queues began to form outside petrol
stations and then at banks and cash
machines people withdrawing their
savings and attempting to head away from
the russian forces
there has been plenty of defiance in
ukraine in recent days
on the street a few hardy souls came out
to support the nation
the flag carried with pride
but in the face of the russian army
there's not much more that they can do
mr ramsey sky news kiev
well heavy fighting has been reported in
mariopol in southeast ukraine one of the
first areas hit when the invasion began
this morning the city is home to
ukraine's main port and lies just six
miles from the donbass region which has
areas controlled by pro-russian
separatists sky correspondent alex rossi
reports now from mariopol
it is a terrifying constant thunder
explosions booming across this coastal
city
it's been going on for hours now
and this is a population in shock they
just stop and stand traumatized by a war
they did not start and do not want
in the distance artillery rains down on
ukrainian positions
the defense of the outskirts may not
last long
some families grab what they can this
little girl carries her bucket and spate
there have already been attacks on
civilian areas this place targeted by
rockets presumably to terrorize the
population happened about half an hour
ago
lots of people live here
quite a few of the windows of the houses
have been blown out by the blast
the front lines are over in that
direction
there is a huge amount of destruction
here and people are worried there could
be another salvo at any time
you see all the broken glass and
brickwork down here this is where this
man lives
jacob shows me inside his house
it's been wrecked
his great-grandson was hit by shrapnel
as he slept
there are still signs of life in the
city center but this is not normal
they're trying to get supplies
no one here knows when the russians will
arrive but they can hear the fighting is
getting closer
there is a feeling of absolute dread in
this city over the last five minutes
we've heard the sound
of very intense artillery barrages on
the outskirts
now some people are coming out they
you can hear it there
they're queuing at this atm for money
they're also stocking up on supplies at
the supermarket checking their phones
calling their relatives really worried
about what is going to happen next
in the queue waiting patiently we find
margarita
she's frightened but defiance
ukrainian forces are trying to fight
setting up positions now inside the city
but as we filmed the war felt very close
with bombs dropping families hunker down
in damp and gloomy basements
they don't know when this storm of fire
will pass
lude miller a mother of two still can't
understand why russia wants to destroy
her country
ukraine is a nation of suffering the
next hours will be filled with misery
and fear as people cower in the dark
from vladimir putin's war machine
alex rossi sky news mario paul
well in kharkiv in eastern ukraine roads
were blocked as residents tried to flee
the closest city to the russian border
many of those who stayed took shelter in
subway stations or queued at hospitals
to donate blood
kharkiv the country's second largest
city is less than 20 miles away from
russia large explosions have been heard
near the city since the early hours of
this morning sky correspondent john
sparks reports now from kharkiv
the people of harkiev now live a new
reality
their city under siege by an enemy
unseen
and the front line isn't far the russian
military sits on its northern outskirts
they awoke with a shock in the center of
this city vladimir putin's operation is
real not imagined
how are you feeling this morning
[Music]
they don't usually queue for the local
supermarket but today was anything but
normal
elena took her prayer book on the
morning shop yep
the competition for petrol and diesel is
fierce
for many are trying to leave the city
alexandra and her partner began to pack
after the first artillery shells hit the
city
we woke up at five o'clock from this
hits yeah yeah
and we were very stressed and worried so
we didn't have enough time to take uh
to take this clothes or something like
that just the most important things yeah
even i don't know if i took everything
important
or uh
but
may god help me and my god help all of
us this the only one thing what i can
say
there are queues everywhere for shops
supermarkets pharmacies
and the occasional thud of artillery
here in the city's northern suburbs
incoming shells and they're not far away
the ukrainian army has taken up
positions on the city's outskirts but
their personnel are badly outnumbered
the russian military crossed the
frontier through multiple checkpoints
and shelled this residential
neighborhood in a place called chihuiv
the fire service said a boy was killed
in the attack
this country knows the price it is
likely to pay
and the people of harkief are getting
prepared
the largest line we witnessed was formed
by those who wanted to give blood
[Music]
ureva havenco took us for a tour
he said he hadn't seen it this busy
since the beginning of the conflict with
russia in 2014.
i'm just doing my job he said the heroes
here are those who give blood
at the central train station
life-changing decisions are made in an
instant
city residents alina and yuri will seek
shelter in neighboring poland and they
worry they'll never return
up
john sparks sky news in harkief eastern
ukraine
well i'm joined now by alex rossi in
mario poll by john incarkiv but first uh
stuart ramsey here in kiev and stuart it
would seem tonight that russian troops
are fighting their way towards this
capital city give us a sense of
the mood
here tonight
very very quiet actually sorry i i i i
it's a bit deafening at the moment
because this is a convoy of um
military uh vehicles uh that have been
just passing us
for the last uh a few seconds or so um i
can't see if there's men in them they
look like uh
transporter troop transporters but apart
from that it is absolutely dead quiet
here this was really busy yesterday
people are out restaurants open all now
completely shut there's going to be a
curfew starting at the top of the hour
so that was to be expected but what a
change mark we have seen in this one day
absolutely everyone is staying indoors
people are very very scared about what's
happening and there is that sense that
the russians are getting nearer and
nearer all the time
stuart thank you very much let's speak
to alex rossi in mario poll and uh alex
just give us a sense of
the strategic importance of that uh
port city where you are
mark we are in the southeast corner of
ukraine it is a place that will almost
certainly be taken in this russian
invasion by forces pushing in from
western russia from the areas at the
moment held by russian-backed
separatists but the other fear is of
course that there are columns of armor
moving up from the crimea which have
already entered ukraine and they will
kettle the soldiers already here
but people are it's a mixture really
here of fear and defiance people are
absolutely terrified about what is going
to unfold over the next few
hours and days um it's a very moody
place at the moment we are under curfew
we've had to move uh from the position
that we were in on the coast because
there are no lights allowed
on the front because there's a fear it
could draw
attention from the russian forces and
potentially draw uh fire so um people
just don't really know what to expect at
all i think the other thing to note of
course is that where we are is within
the donetsk region the donetsk oblast
now that as far as vladimir putin is
concerned although it's occupied at the
moment
and under the control of ukrainian
soldiers he believes that this belongs
to russian-backed separatists so i think
it is almost certainly that the forces
will arrive here they're very close to
the city at the moment we heard some
thunderous bangs on the outskirts where
the ukrainian forces have dug in
but people here really are kind of
holding their breath it is just a matter
of time
yeah i can only imagine alex thank you
very much and finally to john sparks in
kharkiv and john
i mean so close to the russian border
this promises to be a very unnerving
night for the people there
that's absolutely right mark
the second unnerving night because the
artillery barrage began at 5 00 a.m this
morning so there are a lot of people who
haven't had a whole lot of sleep people
know that they are vulnerable here we
are so close to the border it's just 20
miles away you can drive there
in less than an hour and they've had to
listen to this
thud through the day and well into the
night and we've been listening to it
just as we've been waiting to speak to
you and you're right it's really
unnerving and people have been having to
make these really difficult decisions
throughout the day do they do they stay
at home
um
do they do they try and get out do they
uh do they go to the petrol station
queue up for hours and we saw people
with their bags
in the back of
vehicles telling us they were desperate
to go out and the trains are still
running here so there are a lot of
people at the central station people
trying to get to moldova in the south or
people trying to make a very long trip
to poland in the west the president of
poland who says he will welcome refugees
from ukraine they can come so people are
having to make these really difficult
decisions and they're having to make
them in a in an instant so a very
difficult day here
yep okay john thank you very much indeed
and thank you to to alex rossi and mario
paul
and
stuart ramsey here in kiev
so it's a fast moving and changing
situation here michael clark professor
of war studies can tell us now what we
know so far
24 hours ago we were wondering if the
military movement might be restricted to
the donbass but now with that we know
that mr putin is going for broke he's
invading the whole country in a
multi-pronged attack it started in the
donbash region to the east but from kiev
in the north la viv in the west to
odessa in the south there's now been
over 200 attacks taking place since the
start of the day according to the
ukrainian national police service
so let's look at khaki first the most
vulnerable of the big cities in ukraine
near the russian border with lots of
russian speakers
it's not surprising perhaps that russian
forces are about to surround this city
so far russian military attacks look as
if they're only against the ukrainian
military and they're probably hoping
that they'll be able to walk into
undamaged cities that won't try to
defend themselves when they do
we've seen footage appearing to show the
aftermath of an attack on an air base in
shaviv near kharkiv
sky news has gone through an extensive
verification process to corroborate this
video you'll see two impacts that's to
be expected as missile attacks almost
always involve sending two missiles to
each target that's in order to achieve
something close to a 95 chance of
success we can see the before and after
with these latest satellite images
released by communication services
monitoring the situation the first image
taken on monday and in this one from
today where you can see clearly the
aftermath of the attack now to the west
and what should be the safest city in
ukraine lev
far to the west not part of an
industrial area and close to the polish
border
well it may soon find itself hosting an
unknown number of refugees
80 miles south we've seen video of
another missile hitting an air base
there here the ukrainian air base in
irvane francoise 83 miles south of la
vie it was hit by what looks to be a
cruise missile and in the southwest of
ukraine is odessa a historic city
subject to a missile attack where at
least 18 people have been killed
it's a significant port complex
important for russian forces to control
it if they're trying to take the whole
country
in fact a turkish ship on route from
odessa to romania was hit by a bomb on
thursday afternoon in addition ukrainian
authorities say that parts of the
kirshan region along the crimea's coast
northern coast are no longer under their
control so the big question now is what
happens in kiev home to nearly three
million people we've heard reports of a
number of attacks on all sides two power
plants one in the south of the city and
chernobyl to the north as well as a
military base in neighbouring gossamell
all examples of being hit by russian
forces trying to paralyze the
infrastructure
russia's attack is engaged in a
multi-prong defensive now there's a
certain degree of risk in this given the
distribution of the forces that the
russians have put into the field
if mr putin is going to succeed in the
way he seems to expect
then he'll probably have to do it
quickly
michael clark there well in many ways
this is an invasion the west saw coming
but was powerless to stop it happened in
plain sight a buildup of troops and
tanks that took place over almost four
months with joe biden warning weeks ago
that vladimir putin would move into
ukraine
the question now is what exactly putin
wants to achieve and how far he will go
to achieve it our moscow correspondent
diana magnay reports now on putin's
plans
and so
and then somewhat surreally it was
business as usual a meet and greet with
pakistan's president as though he hadn't
just authorized what could be the
biggest military invasion since world
war ii and justified it as though he was
taking on nazi germany
how far is vladimir putin prepared to go
in ukraine do you think pure separation
is
crashing aviation and the iron-tile
missiles system
uh also then
[Music]
ukrainian army should be
surrounded
and
disarmed
all neo-nazi groups i think should be
crashed uh and formation of new uh
uh system of power i suppose that
zerensky will leave keep in
a couple of days from
now
decisive and immediate action was needed
the state newscasters say against
ukrainian aggression they insisted
footage shows fighters on the front line
declaring they'll take this land
[Applause]
and many people back home believe the
narrative
i see this would probably
[Music]
and he said over and over again that he
had no intention of invading and now
he's invading what do you make of that
well
he has to react he has to he has to he
has to help the people in the in the
rombest region
i would say
he is by saying that he's not in
intending to invade
his meaning
it means that he's not intending to
occupy
but public opinion is a mixed bag
it's
awful and i'm really sorry it's and it's
really really sad but i can't do with
this nothing
yeah
we can only sorry
in the kremlin vladimir putin met his
key businessman to work through how to
weather the sanctioned storm
western leaders have tried to emphasize
that they have no quarrel with the
russian people the trouble is the
long-term economic consequences of the
squeeze of the toughest sanctions the
west can muster will be felt by the
people and that will most likely
consolidate anti-western sentiment which
is pretty strong as it is
[Applause]
and there are plenty who don't like
what's happening here anti-war protests
in more than 20 cities across russia
swiftly shut down by police with more
than a thousand detained
no war with ukraine this sign says but
it's too late for that
dana magnay sky news
and diana joins me now live from moscow
and diana it seems that he simply wants
ukraine under his control and to hell
with the
consequences that's what it feels like i
spoke to
two analysts today sergey markov who you
heard from there and another both of
whom said that his goal was regime
change and i think when you look at the
terminology that he's using
demilitarization and de-nazification you
hear this over and over again as though
uh ukraine is awash with far-right
extremists which it is not there are of
course uh far-right elements there is
the azov battalion that has been
fighting against the um separatists for
many years now but it is not a it is not
a government ruled by far-right
nationalists which is the way that
vladimir putin likes to depict it to his
people and i think that when he talks
about denazifying
um the country he means taking out the
leadership and putting them on trial and
sergey markov incredibly menacingly said
um that he thought that neo-nazis would
be taken away and killed the other uh
analyst i spoke to said that he thought
that they would be simply imprisoned but
yes uh it would appear that the
objective is um a a a replacement of the
government in kiev to one that is
friendly to moscow and for russia to
establish uh what pleasant president
putin clearly believes is his rightful
hold over that part of the world but as
you saw in that report there are many
people here who are deeply unhappy with
the decision that he's taken who feel
that it should not have been done in his
name i don't think that we're going to
have a crimea effect like we did after
2014 where his popularity rose sharply i
think you're going to be seeing a lot
more of those protests even though going
out to protest can often mean you just
get bundled in the back of a policeman
okay diana thank you very much indeed
well our security and defense editor
debra haynes is with me now let's talk
about chernobyl first of all under
russian control tonight yes it's a key a
key point of access to the capital here
it's the shortest direct route for
troops we knew they were massing on the
other side of the border in belarus and
they have there's been heavy fighting
there today we had the ukrainian
president coming out and and talking
about it but it seems that the russian
troops we've been told now control that
area a hugely dangerous area anyway the
chernobyl disaster one of the biggest
man-made disasters of our times
now under russian control it means that
russia now has that direct route to kiev
should it choose to do that but
interesting that here we are more than
you know
well coming up to nearly the first day
of this invasion in terms of the 24-hour
cycle and yet they haven't yet moved on
kiev and it's important to note for an
invading force it's much harder to
attack than it is to defend and we are
seeing the ukrainian military defending
tonight well we know it is uh uh the
invasion's underway and it is a big
attack
what is coming
well if it carries on like this we can
expect more at more airstrikes tonight
we woke up this morning didn't we to the
sound of booms in the distance with
precision missile strikes airstrikes
going after key military infrastructure
command and control centers air defense
systems they will run out of targets at
some point if they can continue with
that tempo but they're trying to
[ __ ] the ukrainian military's ability
to defend themselves but it is important
to note that there is a lot of
resistance there are heavy casualties on
both sides and a ukrainian official has
said today that they have the manpower
to resist this invasion but they are
worried about running out of supplies
including ammunition and other weapons
all right deborah thank you very much
well today uh western leaders spoke with
one voice imposing fresh sanctions on
russia in the hope that these measures
will force president putin to think
twice announcing new sanctions at the
white house earlier president biden
called this a dangerous moment for
europe but said that freedom will
prevail
putin is the aggressor putin chose this
war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
today i'm authorizing additional strong
sanctions
and new limitations on what can be
exported to russia
this is going to impose severe cost on
the russian economy both immediately and
over time
we have purposefully designed these
sanctions to maximize the long-term
impact on russia and to minimize the
impact on the united states and our
allies the next few weeks and months we
hard on the people of ukraine
putin has unleashed a great pain on them
but the ukrainian people have known 30
years of independence
they have repeatedly shown that they
will not tolerate anyone who tries to
take their country backwards
this is a dangerous moment for all of
europe
for the freedom around the world
putin has committed an assault on the
very principles that uphold the global
peace
but now
the entire world sees clearly what putin
and his criminal
and and his kremlin allies are really
all about
this was never about a genuine security
concerns on their part
it was always about naked aggression
about putin's desire for empire
by any means necessary
well earlier boris johnson vowed to
[ __ ] the russian economy as he
imposed new sanctions in response to the
invasion calling vladimir putin a
blood-stained aggressor the prime
minister announced plans to exclude
russian banks from the uk and limit the
money held in bank accounts by
russian nationals
also a government source says foreign
secretary liz truss kicked the russian
ambassador out of a meeting earlier
telling him he should be ashamed of
himself
political editor beth rigby reports now
on the uk response
a dark day for europe and for the
decision makers not just in this street
but for people beyond it too
ukrainians gathered here in protest and
in solidarity
with their countrymen under fire
the gravity encapsulated in this
national address the prime minister
dubbing russia a pariah state
president putin of russia has unleashed
war in our european continent
he's attacked a friendly country
without any provocation
and without any credible excuse
our mission
is clear
diplomatically politically economically
and eventually military this hideous and
barbaric venture of vladimir putin must
end in failure in concert with our
allies we will agree a massive package
of economic sanctions designed in time
to hobble the russian economy i say to
the ukrainians in this moment
of agony
we're with you
we're praying for you and your families
and we are on your side
and if the months ahead are grim
and the flame of freedom burns low
i know that it will blaze bright again
in ukraine
the magnitude of this situation etched
on the faces of ministers
ambassador is russia a pariah state are
you scared of sanctions ambassador the
russian ambassador summoned to the
foreign office but the meeting last in
less than 10 minutes diplomacy exhausted
the focus now on sanctions and military
support
as decades of peace in europe give way
to war
early evening in the pm to the commons
laying out the severity of his sanctions
trade restrictions asset freezes russian
aircraft band and new legislation
promised within days today the uk is
announcing the largest and most severe
package of economic sanctions that
russia has ever seen we will continue on
a remorseless mission to squeeze russia
from the global economy piece by piece
cabinet ministers with their heads hung
low
the severity of the situation written
across his face and today mps across
this house in rare agreement the prime
minister listening
will my right honourable friend confirm
that the government is putting in place
every possible economic sanction
so that russia feels absolutely the cold
wind of isolation all of us who believe
in democracy over dictatorship
in the rule of law over the reign of
terror
in freedom over the jackfruit of tyranny
must unite and take a stand
today russia upturned decades of peace
as it launched one of the biggest
military offences that europe's seen
since the second world war an invasion
long feared it was nevertheless shocking
when it came so now the sanctions
ratchet up but western leaders know in
reality they have little hope of
changing the course of this conflict in
the coming days as they bed in for a
protracted crisis
the close of a day that will change the
course of this century
superpowers that have long lived in
peace now at loggerheads with no
certainty about how or when this ends
beth rigby sky news westminster
well joining me now to discuss the
west's response are mark stone in
washington adam parsons in
brussels but first uh beth is uh with us
in westminster and beth i mean the
reality is that uh swinging sanctions
are the only weapon they have
yes that's right mark look all allies
and western leaders have been clear that
putting boots on the ground uh in
ukraine
is not what they intend to do they will
add military support to nato allies but
really as you said the route through
here is sanctions and the prime minister
with a very powerful statement in a
house of parliament where everyone was
unified actually behind the prime
minister had been criticism earlier in
the week hadn't there that the sanctions
were limited to limited but today the
prime minister unleashing what he
claimed to be the largest and most
severe set of sanctions russia has ever
seen he called them ferocious he said
that there would be an asset freeze on
the biggest banks russian citizens would
have limits on deposits of up to 50 000
pounds in the uk to try and limit
wealthy russians and their uh their
their finances in london aeroflot was
banned high x tech high-tech exports to
russia
banned what hasn't been settled yet is
the swift payment system
whether russia will be excluded from
that that would [ __ ] russia banks it
would make trade very difficult not
settled yet
between g7 allies that's still on the
table the prime minister said and really
what are they doing the allies as they
do these sanctions it's a remorseless
mission in the words of the prime
minister to squeeze russia
from the global economy piece by piece
but it's going to take some time and it
won't uh see off those military
incursions this is a much longer term
product project but the prime minister
said his unflinching goal will be made
to make sure putin's venture fails but
this could take months and months to
unfold
okay beth thank you very much let's go
to mark stone in washington and mark
joe biden sending more american troops
to europe and of course this fear
exists doesn't it of a wider conflict
of course it does and i think it was
absolutely the subtext of what he has
been saying today and of his messages
over the course of the past
few weeks it is that that ultimate fear
that goes back so many decades a a
confrontation between the united states
the west
and russia a uh
a something that so many presidents have
had to contemplate with but you have to
go back to to the cuban missile crisis
and jfk to to to get to a moment
as close to this one i think um
you know joe biden has been uh
criticized or people have wondered
whether he is too old to be president
well i think today his age gives him a
unique perspective or a vital
perspective
on history as he contemplates what to do
now and what can he do as you say
sanctions are the only weapon that they
have got precisely because russia is a
nuclear power and they know and they
heard that extraordinary veiled or was
it not that veiled threat from president
putin
last night when he warned anyone who
gets involved and tries to uh to do
anything about what he has done in
ukraine he warned them of consequences
that they will never have felt before
what did that mean he was asked that in
his news conference
was that a threat of nuclear war that is
what president biden was asked an hour
or so ago and he said i don't know what
president putin is threatening but i
know what he has done in terms of the
practicalities well he has announced
further sanctions yes he fell short of
announcing any sort of um cutting off of
the swift uh payment system but he said
that the sanctions that they're putting
in place are actually greater and more
powerful than cutting off the swift
payment system people will argue either
way
on that one but he also made it quite
clear that remember ukraine is not a
nato member but the country's next door
are and he said any attack on any nato
member on one nato member is an attack
on all of them and to that end he had he
is moving yet more troops to the eastern
flank of nato to buttress the nato
defenses
mark thank you very much let's have a
quick word then with adam parsons in
brussels and adam european leaders
meeting again tonight
yes they are they are discussing
sanctions uh a new raft of sanctions
that will be imposed and i have to say
when they arrived and gave some some
introductory thoughts normally this is
quite a sort of bullish
uh political statement sometimes a
little bit stale tonight was anything
but that we saw a succession
particularly leaders from from eastern
europe who looked frightened i have to
say uh one of them the estonian prime
minister kaiju kalas uh say everything
that was predicted actually happened we
hoped it wouldn't but it did the
situation
is grave she talks about people being
taken to siberia in 1947 from her
country and was she said incredulous uh
that history was repeating itself and
also the polish uh prime minister
muroviki saying uh europe is buying lots
of russian gas lots of russian oil
president putin is taking money from us
and he's turning this into aggression
into invasion and destabilizing the
whole of europe president putin doesn't
have a friend
in the place at the moment and the
question is is how will they respond
they will not
uh turn for russia out of the swift
system that won't happen even though i
understand a considerable majority of eu
members do want that this will be about
finance and transport airspace visas and
more sanctions on more banks they say it
will hurt a lot but will it include
swift no it won't
okay adam thank you very much indeed
thanks to to beth rigby and to mark
stone there in washington
well joining me now is baroness ashton
former eu high representative for
foreign affairs and security policy
thank you very much for being with us
and i think my first question is how
dangerous a moment is this for
this continent
extremely dangerous
you know we've watched over these years
the events that have unfolded around
ukraine i was in
kiev i can remember very well throughout
that period
in 2013-14
and
we were deeply concerned when we saw
russian troops moving into crimea
and we did not know if they would stop
there and i think
all of those feelings would have
returned to those of us who were there
then
in remembering that it was a moment of
great crisis and here we are
in a situation which is significantly
worse we do not know
what is in the mind of president putin
where he's going to stop
and indeed what is going to happen over
these coming days
so is european security as we have come
to know it in turmoil tonight
i don't believe it's in turmoil
european security is very much
looked after by nato
the support of the united states and
other nato allies is deeply significant
article 5 of nato an attack on one as an
attack on all is still
extremely important
and there will be ongoing discussions in
brussels at nato
we've seen already the secretary general
stoltenberg talking about what nato will
be doing and europeans will be looking
to that what we are seeing
is a determination in ukraine
that it will choose its own future
and in the end this is the moment in a
sense when president putin
will have lost ukraine forever
have we been
have the west been played by putin on
this issue for years has the west
indulge vladimir putin and and
this is the
is the consequence
i'm not sure i would use the word
indulge i think that there was an
expectation over these years
that a way of living
on the same land on the continent
could be found
that recognized that europe had its
concerns and that russia had its own
concerns too
these issues of
whether all of the nations that were
former soviet union countries that
joined the eu also joined nato have been
in discussion with russia for a long
time
these are issues in terms of the um
the offer that has been made by the
americans for example
about communication about
transparency about building through
confidence building measures
the way in which we operate together so
i don't think he's been indulged but i
do think we are all actually surprised
that we've reached this point
and what about this question um that joe
biden has raised about him
not stopping with ukraine and
threatening
going on to threaten
nato countries well i think this is
something that obviously will be much in
the mind of everybody the leaders
meeting in brussels tonight of the
european union but of course
uh at nato headquarters as well
things are changing in the region if you
look at what was happening in belarus
two years ago this ambition you know
that belarus would become some kind of
eastern version of switzerland the place
where discussion would take place and
crises would be solved look at it now
here it is with russian troops coming
through its territory participating if
you like in everything that's going on
look what's happening in kazakhstan the
change is there
under the new president
it's not a region that is
remaining the same it is in flux
okay
okay baroness ashton thank you very much
for your time this evening and uh before
we go just a piece of breaking news
we're getting and the health ministry uh
here in kiev is saying that 57 people
have been killed in these days in the
violence today and 169
injured it has been a very dark day in
ukraine the
huge invasion began in the early hours
this morning and now what 14 or 15 hours
later things are
calm here at the moment
but people just fear what is to come
much more
at the top of the hour
[Music]
you